Narrator: It's been 10 years
since "Shark Tank"
ignited America's
entrepreneurial spirit.
And we are still blazing
a trail.
For those who take their fate
into their own hands
by working hard...
We are growing
incredibly fast.
We need a shark to help us
take a billion‐dollar bite.
Narrator: ...by working smart...
Are you ready to try the best
tasting drink you've ever had?
Narrator: ...by thinking big...
You simply squeeze the zit,
and that's it.
Narrator:
...and chasing their dreams.
We're stepping up the
dance‐fitness industry
to a whole new level.
Narrator:
And tonight, Skinnygirl mogul
Bethenny Frankel
and branding guru Rohan Oza
join the tank.
I think your valuation
is too steep.
But wait.
There's more.
Take it or leave it.
Don't go fishing.
No one else is gonna make
you an offer. I'm the only
one with creativity.
I'd like to say something!
No, no, no, no, no.
♪♪
Narrator: First into the tank
is an innovative way
to appease a unique obsession.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
I'm Bill Pierce.
And I'm Summer,
Bill's wife.
And I'm Kayla,
Bill's cousin.
And together...
All: We're Team Pop It Pal!
We're seeking $250,000
in exchange for 10% equity
in our company.
Sharks, millions of people
worldwide love popping zits.
Ew! No!
And pimple popping
has gone viral
with thousands of videos
being viewed every day.
But popping pimples is a bad
habit and has nasty side effects
such as germs, scars,
and, let's face it, more zits.
But now you can squeeze
as much as you please.
‐Squeeze as ‐‐
‐That's right, Sharks.
We've invented Pop It Pal,
the world's first‐ever
pimple‐popping simulator.
Oh...
"Simulator"?
‐My God.
‐[ Laughs ] Seriously?!
Summer: Pop It Pal comes
with 16 ready‐made pimples,
which allows you
to relieve stress
and get that extreme
satisfaction
that comes when
popping a pimple.
Ugh!
You simply squeeze the zit,
and that's it.
‐Ew!
‐Oh!
‐But wait, there's more.
Crazy!
Summer: Pop It Pal
is refillable.
There's no longer a need to pick
your face or your partner's.
Bill: And, Sharks,
this is just the beginning.
We're ready to build an empire
of unique obsessions.
So, Sharks...
All: Who's ready
to get things poppin'?
Can we see some, please?
Can we play?
Oh, wow! Do we get samples?
♪♪
Pop the crap
out of pimples.
♪♪
Greiner: I'm afraid.
Frankel: This seems like
a rubber brick sponge.
Cuban: This is like
looking at Kevin's back.
[ Laughter ]
‐Kevin's got it.
‐There's how you do it.
Greiner: Wait, honestly, though,
mine's not working.
Oza: So okay, let's ‐‐
let's rewind a little bit.
This is, um, a placebo...
[ Laughs ]
...for actually popping
your own pimple?
‐Yes.
So, it's to get
the sensation of
"I feel like popping a pimple
on a Tuesday afternoon.
Voilà. That's the pop."
Correct?
‐Yes, sir.
‐How did this come about?
And it works.
There's no question about it.
‐Wait. Mine doesn't work at all.
‐So, I have one more question.
‐Oh, my God. Look at yours.
‐Where is the inside ‐‐
I'm popping like crazy.
What's the consumer
reason for being?
Like, why are we
creating this?
So, driving
down the road one day,
my husband and I
were bouncing off ideas
for possible businesses
that we could start.
‐[ Laughs ] You came to this?!
‐And you thought of this.
And I thought, "My gosh,
I love ‐‐ we love watching
those pimple‐popping
videos online."
‐We do.
‐You do?
Oh! You admit that
on television?
Frankel: Do you guys know
about the Dr. Pimple Popper?
Yes.
But I just want to know
what this stuff is...
I was going to say
the same thing.
...that pop ‐‐ This is ‐‐
‐All‐natural oils and beeswax.
‐Is it edible?
Cheese. You could eat it.
Lori, it's cheese.
You can try it. Eat it.
‐It is not.
What are the numbers?
In the last 4 months,
we have sold $315,000.
‐What?!
‐How much does this cost?
‐Last two months?
‐In the last four months.
‐Oh, four months.
$19.99.
How much does this
cost to make?
Right now, $8.32.
That's too much.
Yeah, that's too much.
Yes, which is why we have been
actively working on ‐‐
But you're selling it.
Right now, he's making them
all out of his house.
I make ‐‐ We've made
12,000 altogether.
We had, uh ‐‐ did very
successful on the Internet.
Are you ‐‐
What's your background, though?
What ‐‐ What were
you doing before?
I worked in
the automotive industry.
I'm familiar with manufacturing.
‐With lubricants?
‐Lubes, obviously.
I put together a homemade mold.
Summer: And my background
is in nursing,
so I love gross things.
Are you full‐time in this?
Hold on. Your background.
Sorry. Go ahead.
Yes.
And I shattered my heel
four years ago.
Uh, we actually ‐‐
And so I couldn't
work as a nurse anymore.
So I needed to find something
that I could do from home
and still be able
to contribute to our family.
Roof:
I am Bill's cousin.
Roof: My background is in
marketing and advertising,
so that's when
we got to work
creating the website,
launching it,
putting together
a social media plan.
How do you protect
this technology?
Right. Just to break it
down ‐‐
‐Do you have a patent?
‐Yes, we ‐‐ right now,
we have a, uh,
utility patent pending...
‐Because this is very serious.
‐...in the U. S.
‐If we're to invest in it...
‐Of course!
...we want know that
these zits are safe.
Bill: So, we have a utility
patent pending in the U. S.
So, the function of the pop
from the silicone.
Why wouldn't you make it
look like a butt or a face?
Why does it look
like a sponge?
That's ‐‐ that's ‐‐
Look, that's their
future product.
Frankel: What?
‐That's next.
‐Exactly.
We do have
an entire line
of unique obsessions
ready to come next.
So are you guys ‐‐ Okay.
So you sell $350,000
worth in 4 months.
That doesn't just happen
accidentally.
What happened?
Well, we started
doing a few videos.
We got over
30 million views...
‐30 million?
‐...in the first three weeks.
In the first three weeks
across how many videos?
‐Wow!
‐Yes.
‐I think there was four major...
‐Four major, but ‐‐
...and then some
played off of that.
O'Leary:
Has it dropped off since?
Has it really
diminished dramatically?
And then people made
their own videos.
Um, we have normalized.
What's normalized mean?
Yes, $50,000 this month.
So, is $50,000 a month...
That's just great.
...what you think would be
a sustainable run rate?
We feel that
it would be a lot more
because our biggest issue
right now is meeting the demand.
We are able to fulfill
the orders in the United States.
No, I get that. But you're
paying too much to make them.
So, if you could
optimize volume...
Yes.
...what would
the new model look like?
Okay.
What could you build them for
in large scale?
So right now, we've been working
with an overseas supplier
to get our costs down
to about $5.
And we're looking ‐‐
‐Why is it so expensive?
‐The silicone.
It sounds to me like,
a lot of peop‐‐
This would be
a curiosity factor for me,
so I understand why you got
so many views in the beginning,
but I don't know about
sustaining sales
or repeat customers.
You know, you want things
that people are gonna
continue to buy.
Yes. And actually,
our pus has ‐‐ is huge for us.
The Pop It Pal Pim‐‐
Pimple Pus,
actually, we have 44%
of our customers
buy our up‐sell
at the ‐‐ at checkout.
You know what? I just got it
to work for the first time.
I mean, Lori,
for crying out loud.
I ‐‐ [ Laughs ]
I'm not a pimple popper!
I'm not!
Maybe you're not
a good pimple popper!
Which is gross.
Let's go back.
So what volume do you need ‐‐
what investment
do I have to make
to get it down to $5 a unit?
Bill:
We know with the initial order
that we're gonna make
in the next month,
we can get 'em down to $5.
How many are you gonna make
next month?
30,000.
And that's at $5.
I still find that too expensive.
Why would you price this
at $2.5 million valuation?
I mean,
let's get serious here.
Okay. So, right now, we are
predominantly on online retail,
but our biggest
issue is that
we have such demand
in these other countries.
We're getting contacted
by distributors ‐‐
‐Where?
‐That makes sense.
Germany and Taiwan...
Ah, the Germans do love
their pimple popping.
‐...and the U. K. and Australia.
‐So, I have to pay for ‐‐
They're huge, but right now,
we can't ship to them very well.
What does next year look like?
What's next year's sales?
Let's go forward.
We're looking to do
$940,000 this year.
What are you gonna make
on $900,000 in this year?
Ideally, $333,000
off the $940,000.
I think you guys
are wonderful.
And I think you're
in the novelty‐gag business.
And I'm in the
practical‐solution business,
so it's not for me.
I'm so sorry.
I'm out.
‐Thank you.
It's very intriguing
'cause you have revenue,
and I've always wanted to have
some zits in my portfolio.
So I'll make you an offer.
[ Chuckles ]
I'll give you the $250,000.
Here's the only way I'll do it.
I have no flexibility.
I want $1.50 a unit
until I get $750,000 back.
So it's a straight
royalty deal,
but it's not in perpetuity.
I would like to see the pus
be multiple colors
so I could add blood to it
and other things.
‐Ew!
‐Make it interesting.
You have indicated that you're
selling these for five bucks,
so I'd like to have
different puses
that I can collect
if I'm into doing this.
‐You're into this.
‐Yeah, green pus, bloody pus.
But I want 5% of the company
in case somebody buys you out
for this patent
if you ever get issued it.
That's a fantastic offer.
Take it right now.
♪♪
Are you taking Kevin's offer?
It's on the table.
No one else is gonna
make you an offer.
I'm the only one with creativity
that can actually
structure things like ‐‐
Of course he is.
They're all confused
about this.
We're not confused.
You just have a demented
obsession with popping pimples.
Look, remember this.
I'm Mr. Wonderful here,
and I didn't even
squeeze your head on.
Being an entrepreneur,
getting creative
is very, very difficult.
And I was blown away
with the speed
with which you got
to $315,000 that quickly.
That's amazing.
But, unlike Kevin, I'm not
a huge, uh, pimple popper.
But each to their own.
I'm out.
I will tell you, like, the whole
popple‐pimping thing...
‐Pimple popping.
‐Popping. [ Laughs ]
The whole English thing
is lost on her.
"The whole
popple‐pimping thing"...
‐You're pimping popples!
‐To me,
popping pimples
is a horrifying experience
'cause it just skeevies me.
So, I'm sorry, but I'm out.
Thank you.            Thank you.
Thank you.
There is only one Mr. Wonderful,
and the chance
to do business with him
is a huge
opportunity for you.
I wouldn't squander it.
Cuban:
So, I‐I like the opportunity.
I think it'd be fun.
So I'll make you an offer.
‐Ugh!
‐I'll give the $250,000,
but I want 25% of the company,
and any distributions,
we all get at the same time.
So, you make money,
I make money.
‐Why give up so much equity?
‐Wow.
That's the offer, $250k.
Now, where I think
I can add value,
other than the obvious, is, um,
I've got great organization that
works with China distribution,
we can help with media,
all the things that are fun,
and take away
some of the hassle.
So, that's the offer.
It's non‐negotiable.
So, you have two great offers.
What are you gonna do?
Guys, that's a lot of equity.
Wow, that's expensive.
[ Whistles ]
♪♪
[ Murmuring ]
Mark, we appreciate
your offer...
but, Kevin, we are
gonna take your deal.
‐Oh!
‐Yes!
Yes!
I like that
bait‐and‐switch there!
"Mark, we are not
gonna go with you."
That's a shock!
‐As it should be.
‐Shocking!
‐We were wrong.
‐That's the way.
We're gonna have
some fun with this.
Thank you so much.
‐Thank you.
That's only, like,
the second time in eight years
I've lost a deal to Kevin.
I just popped
your zit, baby!
[ Laughs ]
I can't believe that just
happened. [ Laughs ]
It's amazing.
Roof:
We went with Kevin's offer over
Mark's today because he gets it.
When it comes to the world
of pimple popping...
‐Absolutely.
‐He gets it.
...you have to get it,
and you have to understand
how many other people
are out there
that actually
love this thing!
♪♪
Narrator: In season five,
Evan Mendelsohn and Nick Morton
landed a deal
with Robert Herjavec
for their ugly holiday sweater
company, Tipsy Elves.
Let's see what
they're up to now.
Morton: Like any startup,
there are bumps along the way,
and our growth hasn't
come without hardship.
Last year, we had
secured a loan
to pay for our holiday
inventory,
but at the last minute,
the loan was pulled.
We had to delay our shipments,
and we even racked up
hundreds of thousands of dollars
in credit‐card debt.
Mendelsohn:
The experience taught us
that for a company of our size,
you really have to
understand the balance
between revenue and profit.
Always have a backup plan,
and really know your numbers.
We pulled through,
and it ended up being
our most successful holiday
season so far.
When we first pitched
on "Shark Tank,"
we had $800,000 in sales,
and since then,
we have $100 million
in gross retail sales.
[ Indistinct conversations ]
‐Hello! Welcome to Tipsy Elves.
‐Hey, there!
‐Thanks for coming.
‐Hi!
Today is our grand opening
of our newest pop‐up shop.
‐Hey!
‐Robert!
This Tipsy Elves
retail store is incredible!
Look at this place!
It's just like
the website.
Very colorful,
it hits you right away.
A lot of people think
retail is dead,
but really, people just want
something that's fun,
fresh, and different.
We have a ball pit,
we have a coloring wall ‐‐
a lot of things to come in
and interact with
in addition to buy
our fun product.
Our goal is to start
with a few pop‐ups this year,
and if it's successful,
the sky's the limit.
You know it's a great idea
when you look at it
and you're like,
"Why didn't you do it before?"
10 years of "Shark Tank" making
people's dreams come true,
and it never gets old.
The Tipsy Elves story
could only happen in America.
We're two guys who quit
our successful careers
who now come into work every day
designing amazing products
and putting smiles
on people's faces.
All: Happy Holidays!
♪♪
Narrator: Next up is
a healthy and convenient way
to feed your little ones.
♪♪
Hey, Sharks,
my name is David Parker.
And I'm Joanna Parker,
and we're from
Englewood, New Jersey.
Welcome.
‐Thank you.
‐[ Laughs ]
We're the founders
of Yumble,
and we're here
seeking $500,000
in exchange for 4% of our
rapidly growing business.
‐Man!
‐Whoa!
Every parent knows
this feeling all too well ‐‐
rushing home
from a crazy day,
frantically cooking
a healthy dinner
your kids absolutely
refuse to eat.
Your kitchen's a mess,
your kids are screaming,
and in the end, you cave,
pulling out processed,
unhealthy food from your freezer
just to make
the temper tantrums stop.
And in the end,
you feel guilty and exhausted.
And that's why
I started Yumble.
David: Yumble is
a weekly subscription
that delivers healthy,
fresh, delicious kids' meals
straight to the doors
of busy parents.
No cooking required.
And every meal
that we deliver
comes with a fun activity
and collectible
to keep the kids
excited and engaged.
So who wants to join us
in taking mealtime stress
off of parents'
plates forever?
‐Let's do it!
‐You've got some samples.
‐Let's get some food.
‐Can we get some food?
'Cause I'm a little bit
hungry.
Joanna: Great. David's gonna
pass out some food.
We're ready to Yumble!
Joanna:
What you'll notice on the side
is our welcome packet,
which comes with our deliveries.
It includes a welcome note
for the parents...
Greiner: Thank you.
...to walk them through
the process and the product.
And it also includes
some coins and collectibles
for the children.
‐Oh, cute! Are these stickers?
‐Those are trading cards.
‐Oh!
So, all of you
have the chicken pops.
They taste like chicken nuggets.
They look like cake pops.
But they're made from premium,
antibiotic‐free, hormone‐free
white meat chicken.
‐Very good.
Then you all have one of our
handmade, baked empanadas.
‐This empanada's terrific.
‐The empanada is excellent.
Mmm!
Then you have
our Smac N' Cheese cups.
Tastes like mac and cheese,
but believe it or not,
It's got as much protein
as a serving of chicken.
Does a plate
come with this?
The plate does not
come with it.
Our meals actually
come in a tray.
And it fits in a lunchbox?
And it can fit
in a lunchbox. Exactly.
Okay, so, this is three meals
a day you're providing?
Parents have a choice
of three different meal plans.
Okay.
They can either order 6 meals,
12 meals, or 24 meals.
Every week, there's
22 different items on the menu
for the customers
to choose from.
O'Leary: You know,
just a few years ago,
we had a company called
"Plated" on "Shark Tank."
They were also
in the meal‐kit business.
They actually got sold to
Albertsons for $300 million.
I was their investor.
It was a very interesting ride,
a very challenging one,
but a great outcome.
Now I really know the numbers
of that business...
‐Yep.
‐...very well.
And so, it's time
to get to the numbers.
So, we have a little bit
more than $1.3 million
in sales already.
Greiner: Wow!
We've been growing at
about a 30‐something percent
growth rate
month over month.
And our
customer‐acquisition cost
blended over the last
year‐to‐date is 40 bucks.
How many total subscribers
do you have right now?
‐Active customers, we have...
‐Active customers, yeah.
‐...a few thousand.
‐Couple thousand.
How ‐‐ what do you
charge a month?
‐It's a weekly subscription.
How much a meal? How much a day?
How much a week?
It ranges right now from
$6.99 a meal to $7.99 a meal.
That includes delivery.
‐And shipping and everything?
It includes
all the collectibles.
Yep. Over 70% of our customers
that sign up
order again
their first chance to reorder.
How much do you spend
on advertising and
marketing and promotion?
So, over the first few months,
we were spending, like,
something like $4,000 a week.
‐A week? Wow.
‐A week.
‐So, that's $48,000.
Yeah,
so in the very beginning,
our customer‐acquisition
costs were higher.
We were a no‐name brand.
We were learning how to
optimize our funnel,
and we were able to get
the customer‐acquisition costs
down from $100 down to $40.
‐Okay.
So, here's the killer question
that all investors have
for this industry that changed
when Amazon bought Whole Foods
and started acquiring
customers in Whole Foods.
Then Albertsons bought Plated
with 36 million customers
going into all the stores.
How are you going to beat guys
that have brick and mortar
that can solicit
their millions of customers
that go in to buy grocery
to even know about you?
Well, you're not cooking here.
Plated, it's not the same model.
This is gonna compete
with Lunchables.
The way to ‐‐
the way to measure it ‐‐
No, I'm gonna talk also!
‐This goes against ‐‐
‐Wait a second. When ‐‐ When ‐‐
At least the lunch.
Beth is a lunch ‐‐
I'd like to say
something, Kevin!
We got to get an answer to that.
But ‐‐ But it's not your world.
It's not Plated.
It is to compete with
Lunchables. And I am
a mother, and I want ‐‐
You're not getting the
customer‐acquisition issue.
I'm talking about the fact
that you're talking about
what's going to happen
in a supermarket.
You keep talking about it
like it's the same thing.
No, but you understand
why that occurred?
Why what occurred?
Because look. Blue Apron's
stock got cut by 78%
within a week after Amazon
bought Whole Foods.
Cuban: Yep. IPO.
He knows exactly
what I'm talking about.
It is not
apples to apples.
I know what you're talking
about. I just think that
it's different.
I know what you're
talking about, but ‐‐
I think there's
a huge difference...
‐Why are you different?
‐...and I think, Bethenny,
you probably are kind of
trying to articulate it.
‐Thank you.
‐[ Laughs ]
We are serving to parents,
and they're not just
walking into a supermarket
and grabbing a meal tha‐‐
‐You're very right.
‐No, i‐it's an ‐‐
From a consumer standpoint,
you're very right.
Branding standpoint,
you're right.
Kevin's point is that
if you don't, at some point,
figure out a retail
partnership strategy,
you will get whacked because the
number‐one player went out there
and got destroyed on market cap,
and it just keeps going south.
♪♪
O'Leary: There is huge risk
in what you're doing.
And for that reason,
and for the fact
that I don't believe
lightning strikes twice,
'cause I was that investor ‐‐
I got out of it alive
with a huge return,
and none of these companies
make any money.
I'm out.
‐Thank you for your time.
‐Thank you.
Cuban: So, guys,
I think you have to anticipate
that an Amazon
or somebody of their size
is going to compete with you.
So, it's not that
you can't survive,
but it may be something
that's an inhibitor
to allow you to thrive.
So, for those reasons, I'm out.
♪♪
I love it.
I'm making you an offer.
This is a marketing play also.
You have a cute gimmick coming,
putting in the lunchbox.
It has an added little toy.
Kids will spend any amount
of money on a Happy Meal...
Yeah. You still have
to acquire the customer.
...to get the toy.
I could help acquire customers
because this is also an
amazing social‐networking play.
‐100%.
‐You need a spokesperson.
‐Yep.
‐And I am a natural food chef.
I have a background
in cooking and food ‐‐
Bethenny's making a
play. Is there an offer
in there, Bethenny?
Well, we were really excited
that Bethenny was gonna be here.
So, um, the $500,000,
but for 15%.
And I would be a spokesperson.
‐Whoo!
‐There you go.
All the issues these guys have
brought up are very valid.
But if that's the way
everyone thought,
entrepreneurs would
never create brands.
There's always
a Walmart or an Amazon
or someone who's
been there, done that,
and your goal is
the branding and the story
has to be unique
and different.
So [Clears throat] I think
the key is you need...
support and understanding
on multiple fronts.
Who's got great strategic
relationships?
And I sit with the top
strategics across the country.
Who's got great retail
relationships,
'cause at some point,
they're a partner?
And then who understands
operationally
how to improve your customer
acquisition, et cetera?
And I think that I'm willing
to give you the $500,000,
but I think your valuation
is too steep.
So, I think that
a fairer valuation
is more like 12% of the company
for the $500,000.
First of all,
thank you for your offer.
And the other thing
I want to throw out is,
if Lori's interested,
I'd love for you
to jump in on this.
And I'm happy
to share it with you.
Narrator: Two sharks are out.
David and Joanna have one offer
from Bethenny for their
kids' meal‐subscription
business Yumble.
But Rohan is also interested
and would like
to partner with Lori.
Greiner: The food is great.
Tried it.
Thank you.
I love your packaging.
Like, everything you're doing
is spot‐on and smart.
Um, Rohan is genius
at building brands.
And I think that
the two of us together
could do really
great things for you.
So, I would like to go in
on his offer 'cause I ‐‐
you made me fall in love
with you and it.
I would like
to say one more thing.
My other job on another show
is 23 weeks with moms,
3 million moms,
18 to 49.
Okay, they both have merit...
250,000 plus,
4 years of college...
...in terms of how they could
promote you. You get it.
...the whole thing.
Stop selling. You got it.
You got two offers.
What are you gonna do?
Talk us through
your thinking, guys.
Okay, so,
here's our thinking.
This is gonna be a multi‐billion
dollar category
in the next few years.
We know this.
We're gonna hit
$5 million of revenue
in our first
full calendar year.
We're gonna hit $35 million
of revenue in 2019,
and that's based on ‐‐
‐So, the counter is...
15% and 12% are too much
for us just in the valuation.
It's just ‐‐ It's just too rich.
‐Okay.
Greiner: And remember, too,
just, you know,
as you counter back, for us,
there is two of us.
‐Yep.
‐Right.
So, you know,
you want us both in there...
David: Right, we want you having
skin in the game.
I'll do it at 6%,
$500,000 right now.
Wow!
‐Do you have a counter for us?
‐Wow.
Because
there's two of us...
I've always admired
everything you do. Thank you.
‐Oh, thank you!
‐So is that a "yes" or not?
Is that a "yes"?
So, background,
I see the potential,
and I get,
you've got...
Right now, or I'm going out.
...money stacked there
that you have to ‐‐
Right now.
I'm not playing around.
H‐Hold on a second. I see that
you have money stacked there...
You have to give him
the consideration because
this is their life.
...ahead of you.
And this is a big decision
for you guys to make.
I'm gonna go. I'm out.
O'Leary: Ouch.
You're out?
♪♪
Well, Bethenny, would you mind
allowing us to...hear their ‐‐‐
Yeah, no, this is one of those
moments in the Tank...
It's your life.
If you feel that this...
...she dropped her offer ‐‐
...is going to go
where you felt.
‐We really, really ‐‐
‐I dropped my offer so much,
and said I was gonna
be a spokesperson...
More than 50%.
...which is worth more than
a million dollars a year.
Take it or leave it.
Don't go fishing.
♪♪
‐Okay, you have a deal.
‐You have a deal.
‐There you go.
‐Thank you.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐I love you!
I love you guys,
but we can't afford to lose it.
Thank you. Thank you.
It's gonna be great.
She dropped it
well below us, 6%.
Yeah, well,
wish 'em good luck.
‐Thank you.
‐Guys, good job.
‐Thank you so, so much.
‐Congratulations, guys.
Oh, my God.
Wow.
‐Congrats.
‐Thank you.
So, you are about to start
a journey into the toughest,
most competitive space there is
in the food industry.
Without question.
You just invested in a sponge
that pops pimples!
‐[ Laughs ]
‐So, sit the ‐‐
And I'm gonna make
more money faster.
Watch me.
We took Bethenny's
deal because
we really couldn't risk
her walking away.
We wanted to hear what
Lori and Rohan had to offer,
but Bethenny is such
a perfect partner for us
that we just had
to jump on it and take it,
and we're super excited.
Thank you, Sir Richard Branson,
and "Shark Tank"
for making my dreams...
a reality.
Since our show's aired,
Locker Board's grown 300%.
We're working with the top
manufacturers in the industry.
Locker Boards are now on Amazon.
Shred hard.
Dream hard.
Work hard.
Happy 10th Anniversary,
"Shark Tank."
Narrator: Next into the tank
is a workout based on
one of the world's most popular
forms of entertainment.
I mean, for real.
♪♪
♪ Hey, hey, hey! ♪
Hey!
♪♪
[ Group sings
in native language ]
‐What?
‐[ Laughs ]
Frankel: [ Laughing ] Sexy.
♪♪
Oh, yeah.
[ Laughs ]
♪♪
[ Tempo quickens,
singing continues ]
♪♪
[ Applause ]
Yes!
‐Whoo!
‐Yeah.
‐I love it!
That's the best intro so far.
Best intro so far.
Huddle up, huddle up,
huddle up.
We'll take it!
We just wanted to say
welcome to the BollyX family,
and we will be right back
after this quick
Bollywood scene change.
[ Dancers cheer, Sharks laugh ]
That was, like, sexy.
Well,
that was a good pitch.
‐Yeah.
‐Next.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, Sharks, I'm Shahil Patel
from Boston, Massachusetts,
and I'm seeking $375,000
in exchange for 8%
of my business...
Whoa!
...BollyX,
the Bollywood Workout.
Sharks, what you just saw
is traditional Bollywood dance.
Bollywood is the film
industry of India,
and it's full
of dancing and music
that makes you feel
like a rock star.
What if we could combine
the fun, the energy,
the excitement of Bollywood
into a workout?
[ Chuckling ]
I love this guy.
BollyX is building
the world's largest
Bollywood‐inspired fitness
platform and community.
We're changing the way America
gets its sweat on,
one shoulder shrug, one cheesy
Bollywood dance move at a time.
‐I love it!
‐[ Laughs ]
Our classes use high intensity
interval training
and can be found live
at a gym near you,
or you can join us online
with BollyX On Demand
from anywhere at any time.
You can even become
an instructor.
Sharks, we're stepping up
the dance‐fitness industry
to a whole‐new level,
Bollywood style.
So tell me, who's ready to get
down and shake their moneymaker?
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Let's do it!
All right, Sharks,
we got a surprise for you.
‐Okay, good.
‐All right?
You guys are gonna be joining us
for a little Bollywood demo.
‐Yay!
‐Awesome.
All right, check it out.
Here we go. Here we go.
‐Oh, great. I love the hat.
‐Love it. I love it.
‐Oh, my God.
‐We got a hat for you.
I love it. I love it.
All right, guys, I'm gonna
break down a couple quick moves.
So check it out.
Here's what's gonna happen.
We're gonna bend those knees
until your shins are vertical.
Hands up, all right?
We're gonna go down, two,
step with the left.
Three, two, one.
Say, "Huh!"
‐Huh!
Down, two, three,
step it back.
Three, two,
let me hear you say...
All: Huh!
All right, level two.
Step. Step. Step, touch.
Nice and easy. Yes. Yes.
Looking good.
Hands up.
Yes.
Pump it up. Here we go!
Go! Go! Go!
Oh, my gosh, my goal is to tire
you out and take all your money.
[ Laughter ]
We end every BollyX class
with a rock‐star pose.
‐Okay.
‐In three...two...one.
‐Hey!
All right. Love it.
Awesome job.
‐Thank you.
‐Round of applause.
Welcome again
to the BollyX fam.
What a workout.
So, we will
catch you guys later.
‐Thanks, guys. Oh, man.
‐Whoo!
It was a few seconds,
and I feel it.
‐So...
‐Yep.
Frankel: ...how did
you get into this?
Um, I actually grew up with two
left feet, believe it or not.
No?
Um, growing up, I was actually
supposed to be a doctor.
Of course you were!
[ Laughter ]
Aren't we all?
Yeah. [Chuckles]
And I left to go to college.
I was doing everything
except for Indian stuff.
And my mom was like,
"Hey, why don't you try
something Indian for a change?
Get in touch with your roots."
And I heard about this college
Bollywood dance team.
And I was like,
"I'm gonna surprise my mom."
So, I auditioned for this team,
barely made it.
And I remember
just being super embarrassed.
I went back to my dorm room,
and I would learn some dance
moves off of online videos,
record myself doing it
in front of the camera,
and then compare
the two things side to side...
Ha! That's great.
‐Nice.
‐...for a year and a half
and straightened out
those two left feet.
‐Wow.
‐And I led the first‐ever
Bollywood dance team
to the semifinals
of "America's Got Talent"...
‐Really?
‐That's amazing!
...back when "Slumdog
Millionaire" came out. Jai Ho!
So, let's talk numbers.
How many locations do you have?
We teach about
500 classes a week.
‐How many locations?
‐At how many locations?
‐Yeah. About 350.
‐350?
‐350 locations?
‐Yes. Yes.
We actually run
a subscription model,
so we train instructors,
and then we license the brand
and our content, our routines.
And the instructors go out
and teach at different gyms.
And what do they charge,
and how much do you ‐‐
how much do
the instructors keep,
and how much do you get?
So, instructors pay us
$20 a month.
Oh, it's just a straight
subscription service.
Just for the
subscription service
and the ability
to use the brand.
‐20 bucks a month is nothing.
‐It's not much.
It is, uh ‐‐ so, well, we've got
1,100 paying subscribers.
‐Per month? 20 bucks?
‐Good for you.
They're paying $20 a month.
We've got roughly $20,000
in that business...
‐A month?
‐...income. Correct. Per month.
Okay, so ‐‐ so, look,
I get, clearly,
on this panel,
the Bollywood component.
But I have to think
about this as an investor,
and I'm trying to understand
how $20,000 a month
gets me to quite
a sporty valuation.
And that's a fair point.
So, we have ‐‐
we have about $1 million
in lifetime sales.
Our gross margins are about 86%.
We are cash‐flow positive.
We actually just crossed that
milestone three months ago.
How many years
have you been in business?
Uh, we've been in business
for five years.
Greiner: Five.
The majority of that revenue
came in the last three years.
That's your only income, the
$20,000 a month, the 20 bucks?
No, no.
So, our vision is to build
the world's biggest
Bollywood‐inspired
fitness community.
So, what we've done is
we've started to put out
samples of our content
on channels like YouTube and our
own BollyX On Demand platform.
And we already have 300 paying
customers on that platform.
‐How much do they pay a month?
‐They pay $9 a month.
So, our real play here
is to utilize the ‐‐
Okay,
that's not bad news at all.
...utilize the on‐demand
platform.
Now we're getting
somewhere.
Is the video so good
that it's entertaining
if you like Bollywood?
Yeah, I do have actually
a video example of it.
Yeah, let's see it.
So, you guys actually
just learned these moves.
There's 400 of those routines.
You can pick based on, like,
low intensity, high intensity ‐‐
This model's also proven.
I know people
that pay monthly
just to do their moves
off their mobile device.
You're not as crazy
as I thought.
I appreciate that.
I'm back at the numbers
for a second.
Sure, sure.
Sure, sure, sure.
What was last year?
What did you do all in?
$315,000 last year.
How much did you make
or lose?
Uh, last year,
I think we lost 600 ‐‐ $600K.
‐Wait, you lost $600K?
‐What?
Well, lost $600K
as in we had ‐‐
we had re‐‐ we invested
$1.7 million into the business.
Doing what?
Building our technology,
building our content.
Building the brand.
Building what technology?
You're doing YouTube videos.
No, no, no.
Our ‐‐ Our platform
that people use
for their instructor.
The at‐home ‐‐
the at‐home online ‐‐
Yeah, but there's
1,000 white‐label VOD
applications out there
and companies
that do it for you.
Well, it's ‐‐ like I said,
we did all the marketing ‐‐
There's nothing
custom about
showing a Bollywood
exercise video.
Who'd you raise
$1.7 million from?
I raised it from friends
and family, all right?
‐Well, how much was it?
‐$1.7 million.
‐$1.7.
‐Yeah, $1.7 million.
‐Ay!
‐I was so excited until now!
♪♪
How much do you have
in the bank right now?
$900,000?
‐$75K.
‐That's it?
Oh! Boy, oh, boy,
oh, boy, oh, boy, oh, boy.
$75K, but we made $6K
last month.
We've been cash‐flow positive
for four months.
No, no, hold on.
You said you lost $600,000.
Yes.
My math is ‐‐
$1.7 less $600, you should ‐‐
That was $1.7 over the course
of five years, so ‐‐
That's even worse!
So how much equity
do you have left now?
Yeah, so I have 25%. Yeah.
‐Okay.
You have a $4.6 million
valuation.
I'm baffled as to how
you get to that valuation.
Like, I love the concept.
I'm emotionally tied to it.
‐Yep.
‐But logically...
I was going off of the
fact that it's a very
high‐gross margin business
and there's a lot
of growth potential.
I'm open to hearing
different offers.
The reality is,
if you don't set
a very high valuation,
you get diluted to nothing.
‐Right.
‐That's a problem.
I feel like you're grasping
for solutions.
Okay.
And I don't get
a sense of confidence
that you know exactly
what you need to do
to get where you want to go.
I hope you get there.
I'm not gonna
be there with you.
For those reasons, I'm out.
All right. Thank you.
It seems like you have
a lot going on,
and you're not
totally focused.
And I think you
have to do one thing
and do it really well,
and then build.
So, I'm so sorry, and I think
you're amazing, but I'm out.
But I'm saying to myself,
"Wow, that's crazy expensive
for $20,000 a month."
I see the opportunity.
There is something here,
but it's not worth $4.6 million.
I'm out.
Like I said,
I'm actually open to offers.
So, if you guys are interested,
I'm open to hearing kind of
what your thoughts are.
I think of all workouts
that I've seen, super fun.
But I always like to have
a really clear
understanding of the plan,
and I don't think
I get that here.
And for that reason,
I regrettably have to go out.
Thank you.
I appreciate that.
[ Clicks tongue ]
Rohan.
It's me, huh?
[ Laughs ]
O'Leary: I hope you feel
the pressure, Rohan.
Look, I'm ‐‐ I'm
definitely conflicted.
I think it's
taken you five years
to zone in on what
you're looking for.
And the problem is,
I think that what you've proven
so far is a taste,
but doesn't give me a clear
line of sight to success.
And the value that you're
putting on the company
and the amount of money required
is too high for me to say,
"Damn it, I'm gonna
follow my passion."
Economically, I can't back it,
so, unfortunately, I'm out.
♪♪
Fair.
Well, I appreciate
all of your time.
‐Good luck, man. Congrats.
‐All right, take it easy, guys.
Thank you so much.
‐Thank you.
‐Have a good one.
‐Good luck.
‐Aw!
‐Oh!
Patel: I wish
I could have gotten a deal.
We have a clear plan in place.
We're cash‐flow positive.
So, this is actually a time
for us to really be
celebrating BollyX,
and so I'm still
just focused on that.
I was all excited
'til I hear
he blew $1.7 on videos
and training people.
There is something there.
There's something there.
‐I know. I agree, too.
‐There's something there.
Hey, he got ‐‐ he got Kevin
dancing to Bollywood.
But that valuation
was just crazy.
Oza: 'Cause
it's a start‐up.
♪♪
Narrator: Next up is a
better‐tasting alternative
to a popular health trend.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks,
I'm Allison Ellsworth.
And I'm Stephen Ellsworth.
And together,
we're the co‐founders
of Mother Beverage
based in Dallas, Texas.
We're here
seeking $400,000
in exchange for 10% equity
in our company.
All right, Sharks, who wants
to take a shot with me?
‐Shot time!
‐Always.
Who wants to take a shot?
Shots?
Ooh.
We put shots down
in front of you.
See who's brave.
‐Are we really gonna shot it?
‐Do we get a flavor?
‐No toast?
‐Ready? Cheers.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Ooh!
[ Coughs ]
‐Oh, it's apple cider vinegar.
‐[ Coughs ]
‐Pbht!
‐Aah.
‐Whoo!
‐[ Coughs ]
Oh, my God.
‐So, as you guys know by now,
that was a shot
of apple cider vinegar.
Oh, my God!
Well, I started drinking
apple cider vinegar, or ACV,
to detox and lose weight.
I loved the way it made me feel,
but the taste was so strong.
So, we created...
Mother Beverage.
Mother Beverage
is an all‐natural,
sparkling probiotic drink
made with organic
fruits and herbs,
and, most importantly,
apple cider vinegar.
They're light,
crisp, refreshing,
and the best part ‐‐
there's only two to four grams
of sugar per bottle.
So, what do you say, Sharks?
Are you ready to try
the best‐tasting
apple cider vinegar
drink you've ever had?
Cheers to your health!
I'm still dying.
Well, we've got some samples
here for you today.
Yeah, you'd better ‐‐ you need
to give us some samples.
You needed something
to compare to.
This is much better. I promise.
‐I'm still tearing.
Yeah, you should have
warned us, though.
‐Seriously.
‐Yeah, it's strong.
You can have this shot.
Would you like another?
Oh, I think
I'm quite all right.
Thank you very much.
I'll take one of these
lovely beverages, though.
[ Air hisses ]
Thank you.
It doesn't taste
as crappy as the shot.
Well, I could taste
the vinegar in it.
It tastes like a sparkling,
sugary soda.
Allison: That's the idea.
So, our top sellers
are lime ginger...
No, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no.
...raspberry rose...
This is the best one.
...our pineapple turmeric,
and blueberry sage.
So, how much
apple cider vinegar is in here?
So, there's a tablespoon
of apple cider vinegar. So ‐‐
And what will that
do for you?
There's a ton of great health
benefits to apple cider vinegar.
Allison has a personal
story about that.
She started drinking it
to detox and to lose weight.
So, if you dilute ACV,
does the function of the
apple cider vinegar still stand?
Allison: Yes.
Or is it pretty much
like you've subdued it?
So, they recommend
to dilute it
because if you just
take it straight, like,
it's hard on your esophagus,
and it's hard on your stomach.
Ours is fully
unpasteurized.
So you want to make
sure it still has all
the health benefits...
Yes.
...intact.
So we've just prepared like,
a pre‐made healthy go‐to option
to get your daily dose
of apple cider vinegar.
So, let's just grant you that it
all works as advertised, right?
Does it still function? Exactly.
Tell us about ‐‐
tell us about the business.
But is it that ‐‐ Oh, sorry.
So, we started
about 18 months ago.
Our lifetime sales
are about $500,000.
What are you gonna
make this year all in?
So, we're projecting
$1 million.
We just received placement
in over 200 locations
in a large national
grocery chain.
Is it Whole Foods?
We are in Whole Foods locally
in the Dallas‐Fort Worth area.
But it was
actually Albertsons.
How much is
this bottle retail?
So, it retails
for $2.99 to $3.59
based on the
retailer's margin.
What's the cost
to make the product?
So, the cost is
anywhere between 78 cents
and 85 cents
a bottle all in.
That's pretty good
for the volumes you have.
The only way I get
out of this thing alive
is somebody buys you
at some point.
‐Sure.
‐There's an exit, right?
‐Yes, sir.
‐And that exit in beverage
seems to be at
around $50 million.
When you establish
some regional market share,
the big guys come
and take you out
as opposed to
doing this themselves
'cause what you're doing,
there's nothing
proprietary about this.
Anybody can knock you off.
But we happen to have
an expert here who built...
Finally, at something.
...billion‐dollar brands
in beverage.
[ Laughter ]
Let me ask a question.
Tell me why these two
are not beverage cockroaches
who are gonna get
crushed by big guys
who want that shelf space back?
The big guys,
what they've done,
is they have
sub‐contracted innovation
to the entrepreneurs
of America.
So, very few brands
are being launched
by the big beverage
companies today.
So they're not cockroaches.
They have a chance at survival?
People want to drink beverages
they feel better about.
In this space,
the first thing is,
do you have
a functional story?
Allison: We do
have a great story.
We both worked in oil and gas
before we did this,
and I was having
a ton of health issues.
I kept going
to different doctors.
I just was sluggish,
bloating, skin problems.
Finally, I read online that
drinking apple cider vinegar
could help with
a lot of those problems.
Within two weeks,
everything had subsided,
but I could not
get over the taste,
so I literally went back
to my kitchen and created this.
We started selling
at farmers markets
and actually,
the Whole Foods buyer
tried our product
at the farmers market
and said, "You guys
have to be in Whole Foods."
Are you now full‐time
into the vinegar deal?
‐Full‐time.
‐How much have you invested?
So, currently,
we've raised about $125,000.
At what valuation?
So, that was at
a $600,000 valuation.
And that was pre‐concept.
And now you're worth
$4 million?
That was pre‐revenue,
based on concept.
That was friends and family.
So a majority of that money
was to literally start
our production facility.
So, you manufacture
this yourself?
‐Yes, sir.
‐Yes.
How big can you get on your
current manufacturing footprint?
Stephen:
60,000 bottles a month.
But we do ‐‐
we have already started
to finance a fully
automated bottling line.
And this will take us up
to 200,000 bottles a week.
But why would you want to be
in the manufacturing business?
I ‐‐ That's what I'm ‐‐
I just can't believe you guys ‐‐
‐Our costs ‐‐
‐That's a disaster.
It keeps our costs down.
We are able ‐‐
Yeah, but you're in the mud.
You're in the weeds.
♪♪
Narrator:
All sharks are still in,
but they are concerned
that Stephen and Allison
are opting to manufacture
their apple cider vinegar
product,
Mother Beverage, on their own
as opposed to using a co‐packer.
Why would you want to be
in the manufacturing business?
I ‐‐ That's what I'm ‐‐ I just
can't believe you guys ‐‐
‐Our costs ‐‐
‐That's a disaster.
It keeps our costs down.
Yeah, but you're in the mud.
You're in the weeds.
The reason that we don't
co‐pack, we wanted to keep
it raw and unpasteurized.
I will tell you that
if I did not do a deal
in my cocktail business,
I would have gotten swallowed.
Everybody did copy me.
By now, everybody's copied me.
Right. Everyone knocked
you off.
And I knew I needed
muscle and distribution.
You need to come in
hot and hard and fast,
and you need a partner 'cause
you're still in the kitchen.
You're not even at phase
zero where you have someone
else doing it for you.
So you need to get
the hell out of the kitchen,
and you need
to start a business,
not an artisanal mom‐and‐pop
beverage business. I'm out.
You're not fully
cockroaches yet.
You're sort of larvae.
You're just starting.
And it's so early,
and you haven't gone through
any of the pressures
of marketing by the big guys
as they give you shelf space.
The thing is,
is with little marketing,
we have the points
of distribution.
Every beverage guy
comes in here,
and the future's so bright,
we got to wear shades.
But you're still
vinegar roaches.
The valuation's insane.
I'm out.
Cuban: Yeah, the problem
is there's no such thing
as just a little marketing.
The hard part
is the scaling part
and taking people's
attention and sales
away from other products.
You're gonna have to raise
a lot more money after this,
and that's the part
I'm concerned about.
And so, as much as I would love
to help a Dallas company,
I'm out.
‐Okay, thank you.
‐Thank you.
I like it. It's great
that it's low calorie.
Um, my only concern is
just struggling
with the competitive edge.
I see your vision,
but I don't think
that you have gotten there yet.
For me, I'll be a customer,
but I won't be a partner.
I'm out.
‐Thank you for that.
Well, there's one shark left.
Then there was one.
‐Yeah.
‐And in the beverage business.
Oza: But actually,
I'm not smart enough
to have created
my own beverage ever.
I find smart entrepreneurs,
um, and I partner with them.
And they're the ones who have
the vision for the brand,
but I've become the number‐one
consigliere for them.
So, I'm gonna give you an offer.
‐Whoa, kitty!
‐Yes!
Gonna give you an offer.
But the valuation is not
what you're gonna want it to be.
Beverage is savage.
As Bethenny will tell you,
I'll tell you, it's savage.
The mathematics
for a company that,
this year,
has done $250,000,
if we take it 12 months,
you're at...
$360,000.
Let's even round it up
to $400,000.
That puts you at
a $1.6‐odd million valuation.
So, for $400,000,
for me to get interested,
it's got to be more like...
25%.
Guys, that is a ridiculously
good offer for you.
I would have never ‐‐
‐Run.
Run like a thief in the night.
‐It is. It's very intriguing.
You ‐‐ You have to take that.
♪♪
Take it!
We'd love to do
business with you.
We'd love to do that.
Boom!
All right!
Good job. Congratulations.
‐We'll make this bank.
‐That's awesome.
‐Thank you, guys.
‐Congratulations, Rohan.
‐Congratulations, guys.
‐Thank you.
‐Yes!
‐Congratulations, you guys.
Thank you so much.
And congratulations
on your baby.
‐Yay!
‐Thank you.
♪♪
Yes!
They're very lucky
to have you as a partner.
‐Yeah. Yeah.
‐Great deal, Rohan. Congrats.
‐Yeah.
Aah!
He'll be a perfect fit.
Yeah, I mean,
we couldn't have asked
for a better ‐‐ better team...
And we'll work
hard for him
to build this company
to support our family.
It's ‐‐ I mean,
we're so excited.
♪♪